تستمر الحرب الغاشمه على غزه فينعكس
العدوان مزيدا من الخسائر الاقتصاديه
للاحتلال الاسرائيلي ويوما بعد يوم تشتد
الازمه فمن ناتج محلي اجمالي فاق نصف
ترليون دولار قبل الحرب تتراوح الخسائر
المتوقعه حسب مصادر حكوميه وغير حكوميه
بين 100
و125 مليار دولار
كخائن مباشره اغلبها خسائر مرتبطه بزياده
الانفاق العسكري في الح
وصلت نسب الخسائر في بعض القطاعات الى 80%
من القطاع الزراعي الى قطاع البناء
والعقارات ثم البنوك ولا سيام السياحه
التي الغي فيها
85% من الحجوزات واكتظ كثير من الفنادق
بالنازحين من الاسرائيليين المنص دمين من
تجرع طعم النزوح للمره الاولى وسط الدخان
القاتم الذي اصبح يلف كل شيء فقدت سوق
العمل نحو 20% من قوتها بين من استدعي
للقتال ومن غادر او اجبر على التوقف
ونتيجه للحرب وعوامل سابقه لها وجد
الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي نفسه في مازق غير
مسبوق بعد ان تجاوزت نسبه الدين العام من
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
62% العام الماضي وسجلت الميزانيه عجزا
تجاوز 4% من اجمالي الناتج المحلي خلال
العام نفسه بعد ان كانت حققت فائضا ب 16%
في العام السابق
2022 وتعزى الاسباب بالطبع الى طوفان
الاقصى القادم هو الاصعب هكذا توقعت
تقديرات الميزانيه الاسرائيليه للعام
الحالي فعجز الموازنه يتوقع ان يتجاوز 6
ونصف في من اجمالي الناتج المحلي يجمع
الاقتصاديون على ان الحرب على غزه وجهت
ضربه قاسيه لقطاع التكنولوجيا الاسرائيلي
الذي يعد احد اهم القطاعات الاقتصاديه
ويضم نحو 6 الاف الشركه ويساهم في نصف
الصادرات وثلث عائدات الضرائب حيث ابلغ
نحو 70% من شركات التقنيه الاسرائيليه عن
تعرضها لاضرار بسبب استدعاء جزء كبير من
موظفيها للخدمه العسكريه وخسرت
الاستثمارات الخارجيه المباشره
40% ظلال داكنه اذا تلقي بثقلها على
الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي وسط مؤشرات مخيبه
للامال ومخاوف من انكماش يطرق الابواب
خلاص منه كما يرى مراقبون الا بوقف الحرب
قبل انتهاء الربع الاول من العام اما غير
ذلك فالخسائر الماديه والمعنويه
والاخلاقيه ستستمر ما استمر العدوان